how many pitch meetings would you
schedule a day
we had them every hour on the hour
so
more than likely we would do so typical
a typical Network executive's day is
usually a breakfast sometimes now these
days obviously not so much but I usually
would start my day with a breakfast then
I'd have a 10 a.m because I was in the
office by 10.
um every now and again like a Tuesday
morning or Monday morning we'd have a
staff meeting at some point during that
week probably Monday or Tuesday where we
go over weekend read
so we go through all of this material
that it can't come in or it would be a
meeting so it would be a 10 a.m 11 A.M a
noon then we go to lunch come back and
we would do either 2 30 or a three
o'clock four o'clock five o'clock
sometimes a six
sometimes those six o'clocks would end
up being
actually at EPN we had seven o'clock
meetings as well so we had those were
usually within the company but it might
have been a programming conversation
with scheduling or with you know
uh you know it would be a budget
conversation whatever it was it was but
we were stacked every single every
single hour
you had something and that's why I say
when you got a chance to you know when
somebody canceled it was like because
those every single lunch was was a was a
meeting and that's another meeting right
it's not just lunch it's a meeting
so uh when I when I had kids I would go
home
I'd get home by eight
and
I usually had to lay down for at least a
half hour before I could even be sane
enough to see my kids who were about to
go to sleep if they hadn't already so
it's a it's a lot
it's a lot and then there are also
sometimes you have dinners so it's a
constant churn of activity and within
all of that you are then the last 10
minutes before the end of the last
meeting or at the end of the last
meeting you 10 minutes maybe you can go
through some of your emails and go
through some of your phone calls and try
to return calls and and try to reply or
read the next script or look at
somebody's credits who's coming in to
pitch you
um so there's always something to do
there's always something to fill your
time it's exhausting
it's exhausting and then imagine you're
managing then the projects that you have
already bought
so let's just say I've already purchased
and I'm going to say at at Fox we
purchased 65 scripts to 85 scripts a
year
um at UPN probably a little bit less
maybe but still probably in the you know
we're we're not talking a couple we're
talking you know 50 60 Scripts
so we're managing all of that material
and giving notes so some of those some
of those are notes calls they're not all
pitches
so there's a lot and then we have to
obviously connect with one another to
say okay what did everybody think
about this before we give notes so
there's a lot of stuff happening during
the day when you're a network executive
and it doesn't end on your weekends
you're still doing on the weekends so
it's a seven day a week job yeah I had
to at EP and I had to make a decision
that Sundays were for myself and my
family but the Saturdays I would work
so I took one day
this is even just after I got married I
needed to Foster my relationship right
so I did make sure that I at least had
one day for reading material and doing
notes or watching cuts and giving those
one Cuts whatever that whatever I was
doing and sometimes you're you're
writing up the document right so it's
not just like I'm reading a script and
verbally giving notes I'm then writing a
document or I'm reading a document that
someone has written and adding my
thoughts before we send it off so
there's again there's process
and then at least one day for relaxation
and was it really relaxation or you were
always available by phone
no I was not available by phone I had to
unplug and that was again that was the
uh stipulation between when I worked at
Fox for Tom Noonan who at the time was a
21st hours you know seven day a week
kind of person and I would get these
crazy calls so early in the morning I
was not prepared and I was like and he
had always read everything way before I
had so I had to be really really fast
and at the time at Fox I was also the
person who had to collect
all of the the information this is so
old school but all of the information
about everything that everybody else was
doing in town so part of my job besides
going to comedy clubs and doing notes
and all of this and reading scripts was
also to Canvas the town and do up a
report that was well Warrior Brothers
just bought these three scripts and
these are the auspices and this is the
log line and you know the status and it
was a multi-page document
so it was terrifying because I was a
person who was like I gotta call so and
so it whatever and Weedle the
information out of them because they
didn't always want to give it to you
sometimes you call the agents but you
had this binder essentially of
information
I will say packets of information about
what everybody's doing what overall
Deals they were having they were
creating
um
who was getting blind scripts you know
whatever it was I had to be the
the Rooter outer of all things
so it was um but again it helped me
create a network of people I I suddenly
had
you know 15 20 people who were my
regular contacts that then exponentially
again grows your network
can any writer that comes in is always
represented it's never a non-represented
writer like someone just cold pitching
well if you well okay so so things
things are things are different if I'm
finding somebody let's just say I'm
finding a playwright they marinate it
may not be represented but the materials
out there right so the playwright is
probably produced the play that's how I
probably know of that playwright so it's
not like it's anything that there's an
issue with me being able to
bring that person in
so sometimes you have to go chase people
who aren't represented but for the most
part people are represented or they have
legal representation or they come in
from a valued Source when I was at at
HBO I because I was in the diversity
Department there was an understanding
that if you were coming to me
we didn't need you to be represented we
didn't need you we needed you to sign a
release form
but we didn't need you to have all the
bells and whistles because we were
discovering that Talent
and I think some a lot of places don't
necessarily
operate that way
you know I was lucky that I they allowed
me that
chapter where people could could fall
out of my desk
how many pitches would you listen to
before green lighting a show
well the process at a broadcast network
it's not quite that
um
it's not really done that way like I
said every every year we would bring in
a certain number of pitches and that was
was
um determined by the budget that I had
so let's just say let's just say I for
sake of argument I have a million
dollars
in my budget
and I'm purchasing scripts from a number
of different kinds of levels of writers
so some are basically getting scales or
whatever it is they're getting a minimum
amount of money because they're brand
new they've never done it before
or we're getting some super high-end
people who've already you know knocked
it out of the park on it another Network
and they're coming in to do another
project for us
so I've got a certain budget the budget
will run out at a certain point usually
around October for for the comedies
um
and or for comedies and dramas it
depends again on how much money you have
in your in your kitty
and
and then we would always Reserve
something because there's there was
usually like a heavy hitter that came in
like at the very last minute there would
be always something super unexpected
that you go oh I really wish I had the
money for that so you reserve a little
bit something in the in your pot for
that
but when the money runs out the money
runs out so again sometimes it's 55
scripts sometimes it's 85 Scripts
and based on that you then get all your
first drafts in or you get all your all
your scripts in by I could say your
final jobs in before the holidays so
just before Christmas break you get all
your scripts in you've already done a
draft or two so you know what's kind of
what's looking good and what's not
looking good
and then when January comes around and
you're back in business after the
holidays that's when you make your
pickups and decide okay of all of these
I have enough to make maybe 10 Pilots or
13 Pilots or whatever the number of
Pilots are
and at a certain point sometimes you
might not want to do a full pilot you
might want to do a presentation you
might want to shoot a few scenes to see
if it's something but you don't
necessarily need to shoot the whole
thing there are times when you must
shoot the whole thing because it's the
only way you're going to really know if
you got something
so we would decide oh we're going to do
three pilots and four presentations
based on the money again
and then and then you'd make your
pickups based on those things that that
panned out
and it's you know then you go you go
into
pilot craziness and all of a sudden
you're off to the races with everybody
else and you're looking for directors
and you're looking for
um
Studio space you're looking for your
um your actors and your competing
against all the other networks that
somebody might want to go to before they
want to come to you and you're doing
your best to scramble to get you know to
get the very best package that you can
the very best you know team of people
and how are you choosing some of the
staff writers
well that comes after you get the pilot
done so let's just say then the pilot
gets shot
you know edit it you see the rough cut
you they you go back and you give your
notes you polish it up and buy May when
the upright fronts were coming up you
then have you know you know which ones
you were you're put putting on your
schedule and which ones you're going to
hold for mid-season as mid-season
replacements
and then you go out and announce it to
the world and somewhere in that that
April delivery of the pilot and the
pickup to series is a couple of weeks
where you pretty much know what's going
to end up on the schedule and you've
you've sort of tipped a hand to the
people who are producing those things
and you go all right it's looking really
good you should probably start to read
some scripts and get some stuff or a
you're not it's on the bubble or it's
not going to work out and then yeah
those that's the problem of the of the
showrunner to go assemble that team and
start reading people and because we've
worked with a lot of writers we will
have an idea of kind of who we would
like
to have in that group and if the
showrunner's amenable and meets and
likes those people then great and if
they don't they might have their own
ideas it's a little bit of a negotiation
to decide you know who's going to get on
staff
now that I've been a writer in a
writer's room
I think I even know even more how
important it is to get the right group
of people and how much the showrunner
really needs to rely on particularly
people at the top who are going to
execute that
that goal even when they're not in the
room I knew about it before but it's
like you really see it in action when
it's when you're sitting there you know
in that writer's room it's really
important to have the right mix
that's interesting so what does that
mean when someone's not in the room and
they can execute so they can then give
notes over the phone or no no I just
mean that when you're when you're
running a show as a as a writing
showrunner
there's other things that you have to
take care of so you are also when you're
launching your show you're doing a press
you're in the um you're in the edit Bay
doing post you're managing your talent
you are putting out fires left and right
you're talking to the network you're
pitching another new stories to the
network and the studio so there's a lot
of other things that happen that's why
the showrunner is so important and then
you might have a head writer who is
taking care of running the physical room
while that while you were handling other
things you may also be that person who
must dip back in you might have a
non-writing executive producer who might
handle all that so when I was executive
producing a show it was a drama series
we handled a lot of the other things we
were in the writer we were in the edit
Bay all the time we were selecting the
music We Were
doing the spotting we were doing the
color correction we were in the posts in
the post
you know world but we were also dealing
with well we had a cast uh not a Cassidy
a costumer who was cycling out we had to
get a new costume designer we had you
know crew changes or other issues we had
to figure out what it's supposed to look
like so there's other things other
decisions that have to be made
that have to go along with the show the
physical writing of the show
so there's a lot of
you know kettle's boiling sure I know
I'm mixing my metaphors like no no no no
no now I'm getting a better picture of
it right okay so you've got the writer's
room they're there 14 hours a day I
guess well they commit it like it's a 10
to
six kind of job okay all right maybe
maybe although there are
legendary shows where they just never
went home like they went home for like a
minute to shower and then came back but
those are old stories sure sure so okay
so maybe eight to ten hours if we're
lucky sure okay so that's its own sort
of moving part and then you've got all
these other decisions that you're making
whether it's the poster or press
um color correction things like that
yeah yeah okay interesting yeah and
managing the managing the machine